recall that you can click on the
timestamp in the description to skip
this intro as there will be a lengthy
introduction this episode may be the
most important theories of everything
video namely we talk about the perils of
attempting to understand consciousness
theories of everything even the ufo
phenomenon these are aspects which
almost no one talks about because of
this i've written some notes so i'm
going to proceed to read you'll find
that those who think of themselves as
gurus tend to believe that almost all
their lessons apply to almost everyone
at almost all times though it doesn't
take into account where you may be
psychologically certain spiritual
teachers or people who consider
themselves to be enlightened suggest
that you should understand their point
of view and if you resist their truths
it's because of deleterious fear and
they do so without the consideration of
the mental state of you also without a
conception of salutary fear slash
uneasiness this episode serves as a
cautionary tale for those who are
seriously trying to investigate
fundamental reality how to identify when
you're on a nourishing track versus
being off track etc again this may be
the most important of all the theories
of everything content the push to not
feel fear slash not feel the ego quote
unquote
etc can be dangerous not because the
lesson is false though it may be but
because of the social pressure around
those words in fact there's a
universally frowned upon quality called
being egotistical ego is embedded in it
and also to be seen as retreating is the
same as being seen as being defensive
which is the same as being fearful which
is seen as being lower on the spiritual
hierarchy perhaps it's true that you
should feel less disquieted about
certain facts though perhaps your
disquiet is justified for where you are
now and that's okay it's 100
okay it took me about one year to
realize that in fact perhaps more than
one year took me over one year to
realize that these spiritual lessons
tend to not have the physics notion of
path dependence perhaps you shouldn't
uncritically adopt an eastern practice
in a western world and vice versa or
perhaps certain truths are dependent on
the path that is where you are now
rather than being independent of
anything frankly it's embarrassing to
reveal myself as so
selfish and malicious and
cowardly
and to do so so unguardedly to carl
fristen and even to you
as i'm a
as i'm a relatively thin-skinned person
at least currently i am but hopefully in
the end it's a net benefit the dangers
of going on to journeys of
investigations into consciousness the
self computational reality and even the
phenomenon as it can lead to a spiral
down some viciously dark paths that are
at least ostensibly irrevocable while
having certainty that your new founded
conception of reality is indeed truthful
while i don't like to state personal
opinions because i generally don't have
many strong views and the views that i
do have are fickle changing week by week
sometimes my current conclusion is that
if it's not life affirming if it's not
loving if it's not something you can
tell others without others being
horrified and frightened for you then
use that as a sign that what you're
experiencing or what you're feeling or
what you think is not truthful please
seek help don't suffer alone you're not
alone and you can verify that simply by
talking to as many people as you can if
you're listening to this podcast then
it's likely because you at least have
some trust in it so trust that statement
or at least test that statement out now
on to the guest carl fristen is a
professor of neuroscience at university
college london and is one of the most
cited individuals in his field he's also
the inventor of the free energy
principle and is someone who's made
advances in the field of active
inference that's matched almost by no
one he may be one of the most insightful
and brilliant people on the planet i've
been lucky enough to speak to carl
before in a substantive 4-hour podcast
linked below which is best watched at
least twice to properly understand this
episode is an outlier in the toe channel
because this will serve as an
introduction to that episode as many
after watching that we're still unclear
as to what the free energy principle is
if you feel like you're lost that's okay
let that be a theme understanding is
less like a light switch and more like a
stove top that is it's not like all of a
sudden you have an insight and then you
understand some phenomenon you went from
zero to one it's more like you get a
gradual increase in understanding where
a modicum here makes more sense and then
a smidge in here as wheeler says and i
like to quote the point isn't to drink
from the fire hose but instead to get
wet trusting that your conscious
befuddlement is part of the process and
unconsciously more is becoming clear
click on the timestamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the underrived nature of
reality the constitutional laws that
govern it provided those laws exist at
all and are even noble to us if you
enjoy witnessing and engaging with
others on the topics of psychology
consciousness physics etc the channel's
themes then do consider going to the
discord and the subreddit which are
linked in the description there's also a
link to the patreon that is patreon.com
kirchheim uncle if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuously
groups visit brilliant.org slash tow
t-o-e to get 20 off an annual
subscription and i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking the second sponsor is algo now
algo is an end to end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the toe podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy let's do an
introduction once more so what is the
free energy principle specifically
specifically its relationship to a
theory of everything as that's what this
channel is about
right um
so
my usual response here is do you want
the the high road or the la or the or
the low road
um
let's take the high road uh given that
we're talking about theories of
everything um
so
the free energy principle is a principle
of least action
so it's a method really it's put most
simply a method that allows you to
identify the most likely dynamics the
most likely way a process will unfold
what is the process that we're talking
about here um but we're talking about
things like you and me particles or
people
um so the first thing to note is that
you can
apply
standard variational principles of least
action to any system specifically a
random dynamical system of the kind that
could be described by say a launch van
equation that underwrites most of the
physics we know
but the special thing about the free
energy principle
is it tries to understand the
relationship of something
in relation to everything else
so you're starting from the premise that
something exists and then you have to
think carefully
what is a thing and how do i distinguish
it from something else so immediately
you start you have to introduce a
partition
between the states of things
um that comprise states that are
internal to the thing and states that
are outside the thing and
thereby in think carefully about how
those states are coupled and what
happens is that you have to introduce a
further set of states known as blanket
states
that constitute a markov blanket that uh
mediate a bidirectional exchange between
the internal states and the external
states so you've got this um notion now
of taking the states of any universe
any system that you want to try and
understand
and partitioning it or carving it into
four subsets internal external and then
sensory inactive states that constitute
the blanket states where the active
states mediate the effects of the
internal on the external on the inside
on the outside
and the sensory states conversely
mediate the influences of the external
on the internal
so with this particular partition which
you wouldn't need if you wanted to now
just move on and develop
um
say quantum mechanics or statistical
mechanics or lagrangian classical
mechanics we're now in the special case
of dealing with a system that has this
partition and in this special case
those conventional variational
principles of least action
translate into or
can be used
to associate the paths of least action
the most likely paths that the system
will take particularly the states of the
particle or person that we're talking
about
we can associate those paths at least
action with paths that minimize
something called variational free energy
so that's basically it and then the
story as well what's what's variation
free energy well variational free energy
is
as with all actions in physics it's just
a um a path integral or a time integral
uh a sum an accumulation of uh a
functional usually known as a lagrangian
where in this instance the funk the
functional in question this variational
free energy
can be read as exactly the same quantity
that statisticians
um psychologists
people trying to understand data
would treat as
a proxy for
the evidence for some model of the world
so this is known as bayesian model
evidence
statistically it's also known as a
marginal likelihood the likelihood of
these
sensory data the sensory the path
through the sensory states
under a particular model that would try
to explain a hypothesis that would try
to explain those data
so
you've got this interpretation or
certainly the fact that the functional
form
of this variation free energy that is
being minimized by the paths of least
action of the autonomous the active and
the internal states of something a
particle or a person
now looks as if it is trying to minimize
a quantity which provides an
approximation or a negative
approximation
to
marginal likelihood or moral evidencing
so in other words it looks as if the
most likely paths are trying to maximize
model evidence
so
one can read that in many different ways
one can read that um and
as jakob howie has read it
a philosopher a neuroscientist who
has a commitment and understanding to
this kind of formulation uh as self
evidencing literally
interacting with your
environment
actively inferring engaging with your
experienced world your eco niche
in a way that looks as if you're trying
to solicit
the most evidence
for your model of that world
this quantity is also found in machine
learning it's known as an evidence lower
bound i should um qualify or just
clarify that in machine learning this
free energy is the reverse of the free
energy used in physics so in machine
learning they try to maximize the
negative free energy um aka an evidence
lower bound or elbow um while in physics
you're you're always articulated in
terms of minimizing a potential energy
or minimizing in the citizens of
variation free energy
so you'll find that exactly that the
same functional the same quantity the
same measure
of
uh the goodness of some model
of how you think your sensations your
sensorium was generated
in terms of
the you know this
variational free energy
that leads you to an interpretation of
people particle persons
inferring
accumulating evidence making inferences
about the states of the world that are
generating their sensations
so that in a nutshell or perhaps not at
our channel is isn't a formal
explanation of the free energy principle
i did so slipping at the beginning
very much like um
things which you you know you may be
familiar with when you were at school
say hamilton's principle of station
reaction
it is
just a method you know it allows you
um to identify predict simulate engineer
those trajectories those paths those
dynamics those processes
um that will um minimize
the
this this action functional or the path
integral of the variation of free energy
so what that means is that
if you now understand um or have at hand
the functional form
of your variation free energy
that depends upon
posterior beliefs or beliefs about the
outside world under a generative model
quite simply a probability density over
the external causes of the
consequences that are the sensory states
and then you can use that methodology
use that principle to start to simulate
to build sentient artifacts that behave
in the way that we assume under the free
energy principle that you and i are
behaving let's see if i can make a
nutshell of the nutshell for some people
who are more familiar with physics so
let's say you have a ball you want to
know the dynamics of the ball you can
understand this with newtonian force and
that's useful for certain calculations
or you can think of it as minimizing a
lagrangian and then that actually
provides a more useful for most cases
way of calculating the trajectory of the
ball so then
right there when i said ball we've
identified the ball now here you're not
just limiting yourself to balls you're
saying let's say cells instead of
talking about people because we can
break it down simply at least for me for
myself i find it much more easy to think
of a cell okay so then we want to know
what are the dynamics of the cell how is
the cell a single cell going to act
okay firstly the first step would be
identifying that cell and
when you mention the word markov blanket
that's a way of identifying what this
object is because in order to identify
what an object is it's often useful to
identify what it isn't at the same time
what it is and isn't so that markov
blanket delimits the cell now is that
correct so far absolutely yeah so you
know i think the cell is a perfect
example here you've got you know
a cell is just defined by the boundary
which would be the surface of the cell
and that would essentially be the
sensory states that i was talking about
before
the insides the intracellular states
would be the internal states and then
the milieu in which that cell lives
which is usually in
a bunch or a family of other cells
will constitute all the external states
so
you've made the very first step just
talking about a cell a thing
you've defined it in terms of this
partition into internal external and the
uh the sensory states that bound and
separate the inside from the outside you
may be asking well where the active
states go for a cell i usually like to
associate those with something called
actin filaments that just lie underneath
the surface the sensory states and
actively push the cell surface say oh
the philia um
the um
the mechanisms that cause motion of the
cell should it move around
so
those parts those states that are
responsible for cellular motility so if
we're now thinking about a moving cell
or a swimming cell for example
and you need to supplement that
partition with with active states so
that's absolutely the first step um and
then you're going to go on and now
translate the ball what's the ball
in this in this metaphor
you also mentioned the word
bi-directional earlier and when i was
learning about this the way that i like
to understand this was that in computer
science generally computer scientists
think and can only think in terms of you
have an input then there's a black box
and you have an output and that's
essentially computer science in a
nutshell it's a bit more complicated
than that but it's in a nutshell it's
you have an input you perform some
calculation and you get an output the
reason why you said bi-directional at
least the way that i understand it so
please correct this is it's because of
actions in that model where there's
input black box output that's generally
if we want to use the term embody
cognition more on the cognition side so
you're just this black box where you're
impressed with sensory information the
input is your senses you're sensing all
of what's happening and then this output
now
is the actions that generally a computer
sits there but we're creatures in this
world at least we think we're creatures
in a physical world the black box has a
model and then one way of maximizing or
showing that your model is correct is by
updating your model or it's by changing
what you've sensed in order to match the
model now to change what you've sensed
is to act so it's useful to think of two
black boxes so there's one that's
inputting to the other and then the
output goes into the other which is the
external this is the internal this is
the cell it senses and then it acts upon
the world and then that changes the
world which then changes what you sense
so is that the reason that you said
bi-directional
yeah no no i think that's a really
important observation yeah
so you know before we were talking about
these states that separate the inside
from the outside and i made a big thing
that they had comprised sensory and
active states and that there is a
a two-way traffic here and that two-way
traffic instantiates exactly what you're
talking about which is a circular
causality
so you know i use the word
self-evidencing and described it as
soliciting evidence
for
sensory data
that it provides evidence for your model
of what's going on but in soliciting
this is something that a computer would
not normally do a passive or sessile
artifact like a computer it would not be
in charge of nor would it terribly worry
or indeed be equipped with the capacity
to select the inputs to select the data
they had to analyze so just having a
statistical package you give it some
data and it produces an outcome you know
say a p value or some kind of inference
um
so a lot of computing and a lot of
machine learning you give it data and it
provides a prediction or a
classification
that's not the kind of computational
process that is implied by the free
energy principle it's much more as you
put it
inactive it has you know the aspirations
to provide a mathematical image of the
action perception cycle where crucially
you have to go and decide what data
to base your inferences on by
acting upon the world
so
that um that sort of inactive aspect is
the thing that distinguishes this kind
of formalism this calculus is bayesian
calculus which is quintessentially
inactive you know it's not just a um you
know a good computer it can be made a
good computer just by removing active
states if you want to um but that
you know that would be a limiting and a
rather um
by a physically unrealizable and
unsustainable kind of artifact uh you
know
the whole point here is that there is a
uh reciprocal exchange in the world so
your notion of having two black boxes
talking to each other i think it's a
really nice notion
and indeed
when
applying
this principle of least action the free
energy principle
to interesting scenarios um one ends up
very often
putting two
sets of uh internal states each equipped
with markov blankets talking to each
other so the active states of one
blanket
or one particle or one person now
constitute the sensory states of the
other and vice versa so you've got now
two systems trying to model each other
and if their game is to effectively
provide
or solicit the most evidence
for their model of the rest of the world
which is just another
artifact very much like you who's doing
trying to do exactly the same thing
what you are you what will inevitably
emerge
from that joint minimization or free
energy
or the maximization of marginal
likelihood is the kind of active
engagement that renders say you and me
as the two black boxes renders us
mutually predictable so what we will do
is we will come to share the same
generative model the same narrative so
that i can predict exactly what you're
going to say next
given that's the kind of thing that i
would say because that's the sort of
world that i'm trying to model so
immediately you have this um
picture
of
the minimization of the joint
variation of free energy or
the um
the the maximization of the joint
marginal likelihood for shared models
and one gets from that
quite compelling and interesting
um
formulations of multi-agent games
communication
synchronization between
con specifics
that all rest upon
trying to resolve uncertainty
in the service of securing actively
enlisting asking questions of the other
black box you asking me questions me
asking you questions
just so i can understand what's going on
out there where you are going on out
there
can any system let's say it's more than
two so in the example that i gave and
that we were talking about there's one
cell and then the external world but
obviously the world is much more complex
than that and let's just imagine
slightly more complicated there's two
cells and then an external world
is it always the case that from the
perspective of one cell you may as well
just
treat the external world even though it
comprises an external world plus another
cell out there can you always treat that
as its own singular black box such that
we can always understand the dynamics as
two black boxes or is there ever a need
for a third a fourth a fifth
i i think i think there probably would
be a need to go if out there if the
external states um
are themselves
um
partitioned into things so if my if my
universe
is um composed of external states that
can
themselves be carved into natural kinds
like other artifacts and objects and air
planets liquids
natural kinds as soon as you talk about
a natural kind you're talking about a
kind of thing as soon as there is a
thing that's in play there's a mark of
blanket so what that tells you is in
principle it was possible to take
all the states that constitute say an
eco niche
and this
find identify
the thing of interest say say me
and my internal states and then i would
um identify my blanket states and then i
got the rest of the states but now i can
start again i can find another set of
internal states and identify its blanket
states and then take those states off
the table and then start again and
recursively tile all the external states
so that now i've eliminated effectively
external states and replaced them by the
internal and the blanket states of all
other things
and in on that view
what happens is that because
there's a
um
a statistical
insulation or separation of internal and
external states by the blanket states
that means i can never see your internal
states i don't need to know your
internal states
because everything that is
knowable about your internal states is
on the surface on your blanket states
what so now the picture that emerges is
an ensemble of things
natural kinds
um
that are coupled to each other
via their blanket states
no
no no individual particle or person or
thing
um
will ever be have access to the internal
states of anything else
but there will be
um coupling and influences that are
mediated by the blanket states the
active states
and possibly the sensory states
mathematically you can actually have the
sensory states also influencing the
outside but for simplicity let's let's
assume that sensory states do not
influence external states
it is just the role of acted states to
actually couple back to the outside you
mentioned something extremely
interesting and i want to pick up on
this you said that the sensory states
can influence the external states at
least that's not how i understand it so
how can a sensory state influence an
external state so i said that um
mathematically it is that is possible um
so if you if you think about um
your from a pure from the point of view
of um
somebody who's trying to understand the
statistical behavior the probabilistic
behavior
of a set of dynamics described as
differential equations or your coupled
systems um
then the name of the game really is to
ask
your what
statistical dependencies that define a
markov blanket specifically
a markov blanket renders the internal
states conditionally independent of the
external states given the markov blanket
so that's their role that's what that's
what is implied
by a separation of the inside from the
outside that all you need to know
is the blanket states because given the
blanket states the inside and the
outside are condition independent
so the question now is what kind of
sparse coupling among
all the states at hand give rise to
that conditional independence that
definitively specifies the markov
blanket
it so happens that all you need is the
following rule
internal states can only influence
themselves and active states
external states can only influence
themselves and sensory states that's all
you need so with that
condition in place you now immediately
have a markov blanket or a particular
partition from that follows the
conditional independence and therefore
the interpretation of the
um autonomous dynamics which is
a description of the trajectories or the
paths of the processes taken by the
active and the internal states of a
particular of a particle
um
so
that means that it is actually
mathematically allowable
in the sense that you don't you do not
destroy
that uh that markov blanket or the
statistical properties of that markov
blanket it is allowable for the sensory
states to influence uh active states and
you may be thinking mom that's a bit
silly you know and there's no way in
which my photoreceptors or my
uh you know my the cochlear impu
affect the outside
i think that's absolutely true so for
things like you and me
um
then you would not normally expect the
sensory states to influence the external
states
but that's not the case for much simpler
things
when
when you look at much simpler things
where
most of the dynamical influences the
coupling that we're talking about that
you'd write down in terms of the
differential equations the launch of an
equation
um
most of those influences are basically
short range
so you know we can preclude action at a
distance for example if you're a single
cell you know unless you're next to me i
don't really know what you're up to
i'm having to exclude here all sorts of
interesting things about long-range
electrochemical communication and
electrical gradients and the like but
let's just take
a bag of cells um that
that just diffuse stuff locally they
just
they touch each other and that's the
only way that they can that they can
influence each other is by
being proximate in some euclidean space
so everything's short range now in this
situation you have a very different kind
of structure so here the cell the
sensory states are the cell surface
and when these active states that lie
underneath the cell surface core change
the environment they do so by pushing
the cell surface
into the external milieu and cause
changes in the sensory states the
surface states of other cells so being a
cell is probably a good example of where
your sensory states which just are your
surface states
um actually do all the heavy lifting in
terms of changing the outside the
spatial
spatial relationship with all the other
cells that you're co-inhabiting a
particular organ uh for example
so um you know it's a little bit
counter-intuitive um but i think a
really interesting um sort of you know
thought experiment um and actually a
practical uh consideration when it comes
to
looking at the different ways in which
um
insides couple to outsides and the
nature of interactions between the
internal states of something in the
external states of something um and we
sort of take it for granted that we can
do action at a distance you know uh
literally i can talk to you in canada
while you're talking live in london um
you know that
that that is that is a beautiful example
of this action to distance
um that
means that you know we have quite a
special um
kind of coupling between our sensory
states and our active states that is not
um
a gift
of very simple um cellular-like
structures or automata
that can't interpret signals um or be
subject to or be sensitive to
influences uh at a distance just so you
know or for people who are listening and
if this wasn't obvious enough the free
energy principle is famous for or
perhaps infamous for being somewhat
inscrutable for people who have a
physics background or math background
what would be the minimum prerequisites
this is how i like to conceptualize the
podcast before i interview someone i
think about okay what are all the pieces
of knowledge i need to know prior to
interviewing them so obvious example is
let's say qft you need to understand
classical mechanics or invariants
quantum mechanics perhaps bundle theory
if you want to understand yang mils and
so on properly so what would be the
prerequisites for someone to properly
understand the free energy principle
let's say if they have a math or physics
background
it wouldn't be
it would be probably much less than
you'd expect to encounter
a university i think you'd certainly
need to know
um sort of you know
the basics of variational calculus and
it would be really nice if you
understood where a lagrangian come from
came from
and
to understand the simplicity of action
you know basically you know exactly
hamilton's principle of least action and
how that inherits from patheticals of
lagrangians and
how that arises from um
dynamical systems theory of a very
simple sort where you can write down any
random dynamical system as you know a
stochastic differential equation or a
launch valve equation
i think
that's probably quite sufficient you
know what um
what you would need i think um
to
appreciate all the interpretational
richness afforded by
what happens to
the paths of least action when you have
a mark of blanket
you need to know a little bit of
probability theory you need to know what
a conditional distribution is you need
to know uh the important you know what
have an intuition as to what is meant by
model evidence for example or marginal
likelihood so uh you know whether
whether i would imagine you know a
week's um um foraging on uh wikipedia
you could probably acquire that if you
know if you felt flu if you were fluent
already
and sort of um
uh in path integral like formulations of
the kind you can find on wikipedia so
that you certainly wouldn't need
you know what sort of bundles where you
wouldn't need category theory you
wouldn't need to know anything about
gauge theories um
you you you know you wouldn't even you
wouldn't even you need to know about
lagrange multipliers yeah but you need
to know um
you know
the basics of how to uh
how how to understand um differential
equations with you know with random
fluctuations with a probabilistic or
stochastic aspect to them and how you
can understand paths of least action uh
in these kinds of systems your example
of wikipedia is
is on point because the way that i
conceptualized this interview this
podcast and the way that we spoke about
it prior to going on air via emails is
it's going to be tendril like a gossamer
like where you have these words
i'm imagining what you're saying is like
a wikipedia page and you say certain
keywords which would be if you were a
wikipedia page underlined in blue and
worthy of their own investigation in and
of themselves so some of these i'm going
to pick out and interrupt you
sometimes and i apologize for that like
i did earlier
in order to
in order to properly set the
prerequisites because we had a four hour
behemoth before and that was meant to
serve as an introduction to the free
energy principle however there are some
people who were still uncertain as to
exactly what the free energy principle
is so this will serve as an introduction
to that introduction
okay
you mentioned marginal likelihood slash
model evidencing and i believe you see
those two as the same and i'm unclear as
to what any of those two are so can you
give an explanation what is model
evidencing marginal likelihood
excellent question so this is where
you would need to be slightly fluent um
in the
the concepts and constructs that
statisticians um would bring to the
table so
um
if i now um want to use probability
theory
um
to articulate the um
the job of a statistician um trying to
make sense of data
and just know that that sense making is
basically the interpretation we're
putting on these paths of least action
and then you you you'd start off by by
understanding the problem in terms of
estimating under uncertainty sort of
assimilating data whilst
quantifying and accommodating
uncertainty due to random effects so you
know the random effects here can be read
as
the random fluctuations or the vena
fluctuations or the innovations in some
stochastic process from the point of
view of the physicist from the point of
view of statistician
those that randomness
is inherited as random effects
observation noise for example would be
one if you were dealing with a state
space model which is really a model of a
dynamical process as the statistician
might use to do data simulation given
some
given some time serious data there may
be a distinction between observation
noise or
sensor noise and the noise
or the random fluctuations on the states
that can't be directly observed that
would be known as state noise or system
noise for example
they both uh you're
describing the same thing but from the
point of view of the statistician these
this is becomes noise or uncertainty or
random effects so how do you deal with
this but basically um you're confronted
with the problem of
some data and you have a hypothesis or a
model
about how those data were generated
by some latent states
sometimes known as hidden states
and hidden
here i think
just as to try and connect it to the
markov blanket they're hidden behind the
markov blanket so the statistician can
if you think of that being in the
internal states they're surrounded
they're enshrouded by a mark of blanket
the data is impressing themselves on the
sensory veil
there's something on the outside that
are latent in the sense that they're
hidden behind this uh this veil so they
only have access to the data they don't
know how
the data were caused so for example they
might have a hypothesis that this drug
treatment
materially affected
um
some
pathophysiology
that reduced the symptoms that were
measurable or recordable by the doctor
but it's only the observable data that
the doctor can get from the patients
that the statistician has at hand now
the statistician now has to infer was
there a drug effect
and what she will do she will create
a generative model that
if there was a drug effect of a certain
size then i'd expect a separation of the
data for example now that generative
model
at the end of the day can always be
written down as a joint probability
density
um over the causes and consequences
where the causes are the latent or the
hidden states
that you are trying to estimate and the
consequences of the observable data that
you have at hand
given that generative model
you can now estimate um given some data
the most likely
hidden or latent states or causes of
that data basically the treatment effect
that you were hypothesized
so that's the posterior distribution
that's the probability
of some hidden state say the external
states the markov blanket given
conditioned upon the data
so that's the holy grail usually of um a
statistical analysis and you know what
your
most classical
inference for example those based on t
tests or f tests um
right through to more sophisticated and
informed uh log odd ratios such as base
factors
these are just scoring
the evidence
for an effective interest expressed in
this latent state space
in terms of the probability of one model
relative to another model
and usually in science that would be the
alternate hypothesis versus the null
hypothesis and then you can look at the
the
ratio of the likelihood of this model or
more specifically the likelihood of the
data given this model divided by the
likelihood of the data given another
model usually the null hypothesis
so to come to our example our example of
um
you know the statistician trying to
infer whether the drug has had a
remedial effect or not what she would do
is compute the probability of her data
with
an effect and then compute the
probability of her data if there was no
effect of the drug so the you know the
data sets from the treatment and the
non-treatment group were treated as from
a single group and then she would use
that to make an inference that there was
indeed an effect
so
that probability the probability of the
data
given a particular model a specific
model be it the alternate hypothesis or
the null hypothesis that's the marginal
likelihood so why is it called a
marginal likelihood well what you've
done is you've estimated given your
generative model
the probability of the data
having marginalized or averaged away
the thing that you don't know which is
the effect size the treatment effect
so
the probability of the data
given a model
is the average probability of the data
given that model and the effect size
averaged under your beliefs about the
effect size
so it that's why it's called a marginal
a marginal likelihood
and
that's a great question because um
you know it actually um
leads one to um
the genesis of variational free energy
on one reading by uh in the context of
richard feynman's pathetic formulation
of quantum electrodynamics
he he had this marginalization problem
um so
he wanted to or one could read the
history as him wanting
um
to evaluate the marginal likelihood
of
paths of say small particles
which would necessarily necessarily
involve
computing or marginalizing
integrating of extremely high
dimensional
probability distributions
which is intractable
so in order to solve the marginalization
or the integration problem to ensure
everything sums to one effectively to
get your partition function
he introduced
the variation free energy
and that was a really clever move
because he converted
what was an intractable
and non-realizable and incomputable
marginalization
or integration problem into a tractable
optimization problem simply by
introducing this variation free energy
which was a band on the marginal
likelihood
so that's why it's called an elbow or an
evidence lower bound simply because it
now becomes a computable object or
mathematical functional
that you can evaluate given some data
and a generative model that is always in
machine learning lower than
the log of the marginal likelihood uh in
my world the physics world is the other
way around but let's stick with the
machine learning world
so the negative
variation free energy of the physicist
is
always smaller than the thing you want
to actually evaluate so if you just
optimize by pushing up the elbow or the
variation free energy until you can't
make it any larger and under the
assumption that the bound the tightness
of the bound is high you've now got a
good approximation to what you were
chasing which is the marginal likelihood
and once the statistician has that
marginal likelihood she can repeat the
process for another model say the null
hypothesis with no treatment effect and
then she can take the ratio of the free
energies the variation free energies and
start to compare the models using base
factors and then go back to the doctors
say look um i am
pretty confident that that drug really
did have an effect and i can say that
because the evidence in your data
suggests that the marginal likelihood of
a hypothesis or a model that included an
effective drug
was
52.6 times greater than the marginal
likelihood if i assume there had been no
no change
so that's where the notion of a marginal
likelihood comes from um so the marginal
marginal likelihood just is the evidence
for a model it just is um the
probability of some data
you know in the present context you know
sensory or from the quality of the
vietnamese principle the sensory states
or the sensory trajectories say time
series
given a particular model marginalizing
away all your beliefs about the
particulars effect size and the
parameters and all all the
quantities that were responsible for
generating those data um
you know
under the structure afforded by by the
model
is that is that is that clear i mean you
know these are the fundaments of um
you know machine learning data
simulations system identification uh and
and your um you could actually argue
this is one way
of a newer new and single scientific
process not quite in using the rhetoric
of
of um karl popper but certainly has this
poparian aspect to him that
every
bit of scientific inquiry
including the way we live our lives is
just about hypothesis testing
and we just generate alternative
explanations for the evidence at hand
and then we try to evaluate the evidence
for this hypothesis relative that
hypothesis
evaluate the marginal likelihood of the
data at hand for this hypothesis versus
that hypothesis this model versus that
model and then we usually commit to the
model with the greatest evidence this
just is evidence-based scientific uh
progress uh um you're having
committed to or selected technically
known as bayesian model selection uh
this hypothesis you then think about
okay what's the next space of hypotheses
or what's the next portfolio of ideas or
models um that i want to now go and
gather evidence for
i think this analogy is quite nice i'm
glad you've let me down this explanation
because because a good scientist then
the good one will generate new
hypotheses
and then the problem contending the
scientist
who's been who's just chasing these
marginal likelihoods or um model
evidences for her models of of her
fielding uh of inquiry
is to design a good experiment
so here we we we come back to the
you know the other side of the coin
that
takes us
beyond machine learning as a black box
sort of you know giving it some inputs
give it an output we now come back to
the design of our experiments how we
actively secure and solicit
the evidence that will best disambiguate
among our hypotheses and i repeat
usually when you're writing scientific
papers it's a null hypothesis there's an
alternate hypothesis but in real life
and in real scientific thinking people
you normally have eight hypotheses or a
hundred hypotheses um um and they're
scoring all of them um
by evaluating the marginal likelihood of
the data that they have carefully
solicited by uh bayes optimal
experimental design to maximally
disambiguate in terms of the marginal
likelihood of the model evidence between
all of their hypotheses
so
that
that sort of brings another aspect of
probability theory to the table
um which would be an important
complement
for somebody wanting to understand
bayesian statistics
the bayes aspect of course is is that
as soon as you start to talk about
conditional distributions of the kind
that are marginal likelihood so it's
conditional in the sense that it's a
probability of some data conditioned
upon a model or given a model having
marginalized away all the parameters of
of that model
and you know building a post area the
probability of my
hidden states
the parameters of my model
given the data
falls out of bayes rules so we're
talking about bayesian inference here
and just straightforward probability
theory
that can be articulated in terms in
terms of bayes rule but there's another
really important application
of bayes rule
which speaks to this sort of inactive
situated uh statistician where
statistician now
is not simply in the service of the
doctor supplying her with data and
asking a particular question
now
the statistician is in charge of
designing the perfect experiment that
gives her the data that allows her to
make the most efficient
and statistically powerful
inference about whether there was a
treatment effect and that's the
that's a problem of optical
experimental design there is an answer
to that it's called the principle of
basal bays optimal design first
articulated by people like um
lindley in the
in the 1950s
and then re-articulated by people like
david mckay
in active learning
and it is if you like the other side of
the bayesian coin when it comes to
[Music]
bayesian assimilation of statistical
assimilation of data and inference
and one could also argue it's the other
side of the coin when it comes to things
like basic decisions theory as well but
that that's a slight distraction uh i
think we just stick with the big idea
here that
you know there are good
just look at it like this if it is the
case that the marginal likelihood is
just the probability of some data
given a model
and your job
is to evaluate
that quantity and usually optimize the
um optimize the uh the marginal
likelihood or maximize the um the
evidence for your model you can either
change the model or you can change the
data
and that means that you've got sort of
two uh two problems to solve as it were
if you cast this as an optimality
problem as a maximization of an evidence
lower bound um or a minimization of
variation free energy from a from a
feminist point of view
and that's i think comes back to your
original uh point about the sort of two
black boxes two computers inferring each
other
um
you know where
there are uh i can either change my mind
about you
uh or i can try and change you by
querying you asking a question
performing an experiment upon you to get
some better um
better data from you that resolves my
uncertainty about you is there a
relationship between changing your
evidence versus changing your model and
the psychoanalytic repression so
repression would be saying you know what
that data doesn't exist let me ignore it
versus the
perhaps a cognitive behavioral therapy
technique would be to say no go out and
perhaps update your model of it view it
differently view the maybe it's our
arachnophobia for example i think it's a
beautiful analogy and you know not
probably beyond an analogy
there are people
in computational psychiatry who think
exactly like that um and you know
you can find articles trends in
cognitive science reviews of the car you
know certainly deal with you know how do
you how do you resolve cognitive
dissonance
how do you understand wishful thinking
um so examples
i think that's a perfect example of
this way
of maximizing the evidence
for your models of the world in that
case it sounds like at least the
colloquial understanding maybe in the
west or maybe throughout the world i'm
unsure is that you should update your
model you shouldn't try to change the
evidence to match your model you should
update your model and in fact there are
some political implications i'm sure
people shout that on the streets across
various political divides so is this an
argument to say that updating the model
is actually the one that should be
primary because the way that i
understand from how you've explained it
is that both are equally valid however
when i look across the world and i look
at how we think just in terms of common
sense psychological advice at least to
us in the 21st century it sounds like
you should update your model um well but
i think you're right to say that you
know it would be um
disingenuous from a mathematical point
of view to privilege the model versus
the data and
um
so how does one choose between those
mathematically how does one i don't i i
don't think you can in the sense you
know you you can't you can't spit a coin
a coin has two two sides to it i mean
um the whole point of this inactivist
take on sense making
um is the it you know you you have to
optimally go and listen to the right
kind of news talk to the right kind of
people um in order to solicit the right
kind of data that's going to maximize
the evidence for your model whilst at
the same time you are updating your
model um sometimes known as basic belief
appetiting um
or certain basic model selection for
example so the two things go hand in
hand i think one way of resolving or
answering your question is just to
say in a political um
or um
perhaps even sort of um
communication science uh sense or
at least
the social aspects of it and what you're
what you're saying is that um
there is now
once you acknowledge that you also are
in charge of getting the data um
then
then you also have to contend with the
problems of how much weight you afford
to that data versus that data and where
you get your data from which news
channels do you uh do
forage
who do you listen to who do you trust
who do you ignore
um
and we do this all the time we do this
in a very skillful way so personally
in terms of deploying
our attention
so if you're an engineer
and you were thinking about
assimilating visual information using a
kalman filter for example
then one of the most artful challenges
or art for resolutions that the camera
filter brings to the table is to get the
kalman gain right how much weight do you
afford
the prediction errors that supply the
update term of a basin or a kalman
filter um and we we do that on the fly
all the time right down to the level of
um
turning on and off
the attention or the precision or the
gain
um afforded
visual information so my favorite
example is um psychotic eye movements um
so just to demonstrate that you know
you know
do this experiment at home you can just
look um from one side of your visual
scene to the other side and back and
forth and back and forth with psychotic
eye movements
and you will not perceive the world
jumping around
however if you reproduce the same visual
impressions just by palpating your eye
in the spirit of hellholes
what's that palpatine what does that
mean yeah if you well you can literally
do this now if you just take your finger
and place it gently on the outer
aspect of your eyeball and just gently
press in
until you see the world shift around and
move around
so
you can see visual motion
that is a consequence of optic flow in
introduced in this instance by you
pushing your retina um translating your
retina with the input fixed
and that is basically exactly the same
from the point of view of the retina the
back of your eyeball as moving the iso
with the um
with the world stationary but notice you
only saw
motion of the world
when you were moving your eyeball
when you move your eyes in the normal
way you don't see that motion
and the reason is that your brain
ignores
visual input
during eye movement and that's called
psychotic suppression so i think it's a
beautiful example of the fact that every
moment we are selectively ignoring
information that is not newsworthy we
are selecting it we don't know we're
doing it but we do it all the time of
course you know at a much more abstract
and epistemic level exactly the same
principles apply when we choose
which newspapers which blog which
twitter accounts to follow um yeah which
friends to talk to which universes to go
to um is it going to be a scholopedia or
a wikipedia no all of these decisions
you know that we make in terms of
securing
the right kind of informative precise
data that will
literally have a salience in the sense
that it complies with the principles of
optimum bayesian design
in the sense that it will resolve the
most uncertainty about what i don't know
so this is you know absolutely crucial
this sort of um
being in charge of the data
even before thinking about the
consequences of your belief updating and
you know you're getting uh just knowing
that you have to listen like that and of
course the you know the um
you know from the from a socio-political
point of view what we're talking about
now is how to disambiguate between fake
news and true
news how to
um
solicit data um in a way that precludes
us being isolationist or precludes as uh
succumbing to um cult like um
ideologies um you know precludes
fundamentalism of a dysfunctional sword
or why is it dysfunctional well usually
because that kind of fundamentalism does
not speak to and does not
um minimize that joint predictability of
that joint free energy that we were
talking about um
several minutes ago
so what what what you will find is that
um
[Music]
that dialectic between changing your
mind on the basis of some evidence and
changing the evidence by uh changing
where you look for that evidence that
that balance is at the heart of action
and perception
and indeed you you could argue the all
of action
is simply in the service of gathering
better data what do you mean by better
those data that res that minimize your
surprise minimize your expected surprise
or your uncertainty resolving
uncertainty about the way you think the
world works and more particularly how
you work in that in that world this
sounds like a deeper issue than just a
political problem it sounds like an
issue for the process of suggesting that
the conclusions that one has come to was
from a dispassionate assessment of the
evidence so you hear people say this
generally people who like to think of
themselves as extremely rational people
who've come to their conclusions because
they have objectively analyzed some
situation it sounds like that is a
doomed project because we're all
sampling different data without
realizing it now is that the case or no
yes no i think that's absolutely right
um
and i don't think there's anything bad
about it i mean that that's just the way
things are so how does one overcome that
what what do we do how is it this the
scientific process seems to work
um well it works because um
the operational definition of working
simply is maximizing the marginal
likelihood so you're at liberty to
actually maximize the margin likely by
either changing the data or changing to
changing the model um so notice that in
this instance
you're not going to make any false
inferences
you know provided that all the data you
solicit is always very consistent with
your model you you won't need to change
your mind
if you've got the wrong model the data
will provide disconfirmatory evidence
and and you may well to try and get data
from another source and if you can do
that and continue engaging until your
model is fit for purpose what you have
basically done is find a niche for
yourself where your ideology your
conceptions your understanding of the
world the world the way the world work
is perfectly fine so you found a
cultural economy or possibly a
physiological
niche or an information eco niche
that suits you and you will have a high
adaptive fitness and survive and persist
in that eco niche
if you can't you move to another one and
so now we have a model of speciation
we have a model of
shared narratives shared convictions
that can be communicated so supply and
teach each other
that
is self-assembling
and
self-constructing
co-created
simply because you are looking for
at the same time you're looking for
information that resolves the
uncertainty about your models of how the
world works
which makes it look as if from the
outside you're basically changing the
world to make your hypotheses come true
and that of course is just another way
of describing action so if we come away
from the sort of um the exchange of
information as a scientist or somebody
who reads the news or somebody who's
trying to do a phd or um
indeed just you know make sense of uh
recent political events uh if we can
bring it back down to
simple things like um moving your eyes
yeah
um
in a sense that is you
[Music]
changing the data
to match
your model
so
if you uh so this falls out of the free
energy principle because you know if
it's the case that the autonomous paths
the dynamics that we um um that um
that constitute are
our active engagement with the world if
they're trying to minimize free energy
and we in this instance minimize free
energy as a prediction error or surprise
um remembering that it's the negative of
the marginal likelihood it's something
if
the probability of these data given my
understanding of my construction of the
world at this point in time
is very very low
then it will have a very very small
marginal likelihood or have a very very
high free energy and therefore it was
surprising given my model of the world
some people like to articulate the other
that surprise in terms of a prediction
what i predicted was going to happen um
is nothing like what i actually sensed
the data i actually got
so
imagine
how
imagine now you
applied that sort of concept that your
the autonomous states that include the
active states are just in the service of
minimizing prediction error
how we would you understand that in
terms of elemental movement and behavior
and one way of understanding that is
that basically your models of say how
you're going to move are actually
realized by creating data that is
consistent with your predictions
so i have in my head
a model a hypothesis
the notion that i'm going to raise my
arm
and
all that's happening
in that um
notion is that that's my belief about
state in the world
and i'm telling my spinal cord and my
musculature and my muscles
that's how i expect the world to be and
then my reflexes are driven by the
prediction errors
driven
by the free energy gradients literally
like the ball rolling down the hill
to realize to change the world so it
supplies the kind of data that i
predicted
i just wanted to mention that um
that notion
of movement
as simply a realization
of predicted
endpoints
intentions to move
is physiologically
fully licensed by things like
equilibrium point hypothesis in motor
control and motor physiology
but it's it goes back even further to
um ideomotor theory so this was in the
victorian age how people understood
movement that basically it was a
physical manifestation of beliefs about
the way my body should be posed or what
my body should be doing
so to me that is if you like an
elemental and quite fundamental example
of
the importance of changing the data not
the model
so if you changed your model in the
context of i'm going to stand up now
and you looked at the data and nothing
is happening you would immediately
change your mind and say oh i'm not
standing up
what would that look like that would
look like parkinson's disease
that would be a failure to properly
attenuate the evidence that are not
moving when i strongly believe that i am
about to move
uh and of course you can understand now
the
pathophysiology um the um the uh of
parkinson's disease
that's due to a failure of
neuronal message passing and
particularly the weight or the gain
afforded proprioceptive information in
that light it's a failure of active
influences the failure of the active
states
to
probably uh respond
to
um
the evidence
that
or change the evidence at hand
so this is a lovely example of ignoring
selectively ignoring just like the
circadic suppression with the eyes
um that enables movement if you didn't
do that we couldn't move so what i'm
trying to say is that you know right
from the the inception of these kinds of
this kind of thinking in the inactive
domain uh in terms of ideomotive theory
the uh there is a there is i think a
fundamental importance of um
you know
of the other side of the coin from
changing your mind which is basically
changing the data uh upon which you make
you you um
which causes you to change your mind
through through sense
and without that we wouldn't have
actions so we can almost say that action
and perception are the two sides of the
same coin the perception is changing
your mind by changing your model to
maximize the marginal likelihood given a
particular model
action just is changing the data by
acting upon the world to maximize the
marginal likelihood basically maximizing
changing the data so the probability of
the data given the model is so
active inference or that coupling of
action perception
is essentially trying to realize your
beliefs about or your models of your
lived world and if you're successful in
doing that you've got the right eco
niche you will have a high marginal
likelihood you know from an evolutionary
perspective you will have
a
high adaptive fitness from a social
perspective you will be uh people will
listen to you
and teach you your job into these
podcasts suggesting you you do indeed
solicit that kind of information uh that
causes people to you know to go to your
channel to attend to your stuff um
simply because they they think they're
going to get good stuff and they're
going to get uncertainty resolving stuff
um so this this this i think is is is
puts the balance back on the uh on
getting the data right or the data data
foraging right okay well perhaps let me
undermine my own credibility here
so a few weeks ago and i think about a
year ago or so we talked and i had some
experience about
and i was worried and you said kurt
don't be worried don't i had some
experience where i thought i heard a
voice it was
at a in a hypnagogic state so i was just
about to fall asleep when
many people
that shouldn't be a state that i
attribute much credence to but i
remember being afraid because i heard my
wife either say okay or just some one
syllable word and then i was so worried
and i worked myself up into anxiety
thinking do i have schizophrenia oh my
gosh
there was no other voices since then but
i was extremely anxious
and then you told me don't worry and
even kurt even if there is there's
medication and many people go through
psychosis and or psychotic breaks and so
on
but luckily i didn't luckily there was
nothing wrong with me and your words did
calm me so thank you for that however
and coincidentally
perhaps not but coincidentally a few
weeks ago
i had a strange experience carl and i
wasn't sure if i was going to bring this
up on the podcast for one reason because
i don't want you to think that i'm
someone who's
beset with psychological issues but on
the other side i am driven by a
filmmaking adage which says that the
more personal the pain the more widely
applicable it is and the opposite is
also false the opposite is false so if
you try to speak generally you end up
speaking to no one
what happened a couple weeks ago
was i had this
sense and it was so and even to talk
about it now is a bit frightening i had
this sense that i was like oh shoot
solipsism is everything in my head just
that thought and i've because i'm on
this podcast and i've entertained many
ideas it's extremely taxing to do so
because i try to take different people's
points of views seriously
and perhaps i shouldn't but i feel like
in order to give them a fair shake i
need to embody them in some way shape or
form so if they say well all is mind for
example that's the idealists
i'm trying to imagine what would that be
like and if someone's a materialist well
what does it mean that this was dead and
it somehow emerged that we have
consciousness either way the point of
that is to say i've been feeling like
for almost a year and a half now just in
a void not sure what is true and what's
not true that's fine i can deal with
that except that that led me to this
spiraling of such
it was probably the most terrifying
experience i've ever had in my life
and it took me weeks and i'm still
recovering from it where i felt like
shoot
am i all that exists and then just that
thought alone i'm like i don't want to
believe that that could be the case and
i remember looking at my wife and
thinking is my wife even real how
much of an imbecile and how ungrateful
and how foolish is it and how
that i would even think that i feel bad
that i would even entertain that thought
oh my gosh i'm scared i don't want to go
to the
hospital because i felt like if i was to
truly accept that thought i could i was
on the brink of just losing it into an
insensitive spiral
i became extremely scared of myself and
i think that
i'm the type of person i am an anxious
person
and i am the type of person that tends
to obsess over thoughts
so then i started to obsess over this
and for the past couple weeks i was so
scared so scared of my own mind so
almost like a hypochondriac for mental
disorders where i didn't want to even
look up what's the definition of
schizophrenia or psychosis was because i
was afraid that i would see the signs
everywhere
for example
a few days ago or about a week ago i
remember generally we all speak to
ourselves in our own heads and sometimes
i use the phrase so i don't like that or
i like that i use the word i in my own
internal monologue but sometimes the
word yeah you can do this you can do
this so sometimes you use i and
sometimes they use you
and i imagine we all do that it's
colloquially okay to exchange those two
however then i thought oh shoot
what if i felt distance from my thought
what if the one that's saying you is a
thought speaking to me like a
schizophrenic may hear oh my gosh oh my
gosh i don't want to hear this and i was
so afraid and i felt derealized and
depersonalized when you mentioned
parkinson's earlier that the difference
between the model and then the data it
that didn't strike me as a
symptom of parkinson's the way you were
describing it struck me as a symptom of
derealization
anyway i'm bringing this all up and
actually feel
good about speaking about it it somehow
feels
curative to even voice these concerns
i
well actually i don't know
i don't i don't know why i'm voicing
this mainly to
mainly okay how about this i just
verbally cascaded incoherently perhaps
what are your thoughts on what i just
said the reason i'm saying this one more
time is that people in the comments
section when they view different
theories of what consciousness is what
reality is that's the theories of
everything channel in a nutshell i see
many of them in a similar place where
they feel lost for example i've heard
that some people who
view yoshi box ideas that this all an
illusion or this all simulated
consciousness some people become
suicidal that's actually extremely
terrifying luckily i'm not suicidal
though i'm scared that i could because
i've heard that other people could i'm
not sure if my problem is just
obsessive thoughts
or if it was indicative of something
else and i was so afraid and it's it's
such a scary feeling carl to be afraid
of
one's self to not even be able to sleep
at night because you're afraid of your
own thoughts and what that may lead to
so does any of that make sense and i
know that sounds like it's completely
off field perhaps it's not
no
no no i think i think it follows on
very gracefully but but you've taken it
right now to um
some of the most important aspects of
modeling um which we all contend with
which of course is is um i mean i
mentioned before you know getting
models for our um
um our lived worlds because the most
important part when when we're a baby of
the world is our body so the first thing
we have to do is to build
a model uh of our body and um work out
you know what things that we are able to
move um you know hence those are
babbling and
the rattling um
probably more important that of course
is
exchanges with the mother um and
developing a sense that
mother is an object and
crucially an object that is separate
from me
and that's quite a skillful move and it
takes a lot of my belief updating and
changing your models and building
a coherent um uh explanation for all
your sensations both the political touch
or the
and the physiological introspective
consequences of being settled for
example and being cared for
um
and i'm taking this route to the key
thing which is basically models of self
and selfhood um
so
you know if if we are
um coming back to this picture of uh
some
mathematical universe that i've now
tiled with multiple
markov blankets encapsulating or
defining lots of particles um and
basically we
inhabit a universe that is constituted
by things like us and in initially uh
you know mum and dad and brothers and
sisters and then you know
peers at school and that means that our
models of our lived or experienced world
have to have models of other in it which
means you need to be able to
disambiguate
between
sensations caused by others and
sensations that you caused as a
fundamental
structural aspect of the models you're
going to bring to the table just to live
in a world
which is constituted by creatures like
you
that brings with it you know
something quite special um
which
is
a model that encompasses selfhood
uh so you wouldn't need this if you um
lived in a world that did not involve an
exchange with other con specifics
but because we do live your our world is
constituted by other things like us
we need to be able to contextualize and
make the inference i did that or you did
that or it's my turn or it's your turn
or you've got that intentional stance
and you know i've got this intentional
stance
so just having as part of the generative
model of the hypothesis uh your the
hypothesis that i am me and you and you
is something which characterizes um one
would imagine very high life forms
now we go even higher
to
basically philosophers and people like
you
so if you've got if you have
if you spend your life worrying about
um
what is the self does the self even
exist
most precisely yeah well i mean that
that's that that seems to be the the
essence of your existential angst and
all its attendant um interceptive and
emotional um consequences uh you know do
i exist
and i think really usefully you brought
to uh the table the notions of
de-personalization and de-realization if
this is for physicists then can you
explain to your audience what those
things are because i think that it would
be really useful for people that do not
know what they really are no to be quite
frank carl i didn't want to look up this
exact definition because i know that i'm
a valid inarian and i would just
obsess over myself having these issues
so i can give an explanation of my
experience and then perhaps you can
delineate what the psychopathology is
okay i'll make an aside first some
people say that what we need to do is
realize that the self is an illusion you
can hear this in the more eastern end
and i know that many people who watch
this channel also feel like they take
these people seriously like i took them
seriously and i don't know if that's
exactly true
not whether or not the truth of the self
being an illusion is true but whether or
not that is indeed useful for everyone
it may not be it may be at least for me
it was extremely harmful and perhaps
still is and it may be dependent upon
where you are and psychological
development spiritual development and
sometimes these lessons that are told to
us by philosophers or spiritual gurus or
people who seem like spiritual gurus
perhaps they should be taken with such a
grain of salt and i've come to the
conclusion that if it's not life
affirming then perhaps don't follow that
perhaps use that as a clue that that's a
pathological path and don't do anything
that can be drastic don't give up
because i felt like i was in a state
where i could
snap and feel like well this is all a
dream i remember feeling looking at my
arms and feeling like am i even behind
like right now i'm feeling great and
sorry i don't seem like it but i'm
speaking with you i feel safe i love my
wife i've actually whatever i'm feeling
happy right now and i feel like i would
a month ago which is i'm behind my eyes
and this is a person speaking
a week two weeks ago three weeks ago i
was feeling like
all of that could be a model i could
emulate anyone else's head i could be
anyone else this could all be in my head
so
debilitating destabilizing
walking around feeling like is this a
dream constantly checking my fingers
because that's one of the signs you can
check your for lucid dreaming how many
fingers do you have and then also
feeling bad like why the heck am i
thinking this is a dream shoot what if
it is
just
spiraling spiraling tumbling tumbling
thoughts
okay that's what i had slash still have
to some degree though not right now i
wouldn't say that i'm over it because it
was such a recent experience i'm not
going to say that i've solved it i feel
like it's tapering off luckily anyway
that's what i had i would characterize
that as derealization in the sense that
i didn't feel like it was real i don't
know if it's depersonalization because i
don't know the difference between those
two nor dissociative identity disorder
so i don't know though the differences
between those
where are you basically it's nice you
bring all those three
their phenomenology is very very closely
related but you know
the way you described that that was
almost perfect you know this um
either
a de-realization um
which people normally described uh
describe as they're looking um they are
sensing
um something that doesn't quite seem
real that you know the outside world
seems like it's a movie it's not it's
not it's lost that tangibility there's
no um there's no grip that can be
attained
that reassures you that stuff is
actually out there the other the
converse of course is i'm um i'm no
longer a person um and that could be i
think he'd be even more frightening and
both of these i think speak to um
speak to um this dissociation
that comes with a dissolution of
selfhood or at least once um
construction of explanations for the
self in a lived world
you used a phrase which um i i think was
was quite uh permanent here which is you
know
one should not pursue this kind of
thinking and self-exploration and
introspection unless it is um
affirmatory and and self-affirmatory and
in a sense that's exactly from the sort
of mathematical and dry perspective of
the free energy principle that just is
maximizing model evidence this is
self-evidencing it is you know if you
can affirm through all the right kind of
interactions be the emotional social
sexual um
intellectual um the the this you've got
the right kind of model of your world
which is constituted by people like your
interviewees and your wife and all your
colleagues and then after affirming that
model simply is securing um evidence for
that good model of your
rich
and uncultured world that just is that's
that um that sort of um
affirmatory uh process
however there are dangers
that you um that lurk in the shadows
which you've clearly contended with to
do that properly
to be able to secure the right kind of
evidence that you are
living in a world of positive um
constructive
nourishing
enabling human beings others other
things like you
you have to be able to communicate to be
able to communicate you actually have to
entertain the idea um that
there is there is self and other um and
simply uh you know to engage in turn
taking you need to have this um this
explicit part of your genitive model um
that i am a self
in so doing you will also have um
contextualize as part of your judgement
model itself in a number of different
states
and you need to have remember before we
talk about the good scientists
having a portfolio of hypotheses we're
generating a new set of hypotheses so
that we can now gather evidence of these
hypotheses so that's part of uh what you
are doing i mean you're you know in in
doing these podcasts you are on a
journey
of um developing different hypotheses
about ways of being
the
the danger though when it comes to
different ways of
me as a self
existing is that you can sometimes
lose
entertain the null hypothesis that i am
not a self or i do not exist in a
sentient fashion in a in the fashion of
having particular kinds of cultural
experiences this is a perfectly viable
hypothesis it can be held in a
non-emotional context when you meet
people like philosophers entertain
things like the you know the zombie
hypothesis or brain of that thought
experiments these are all really
interesting interesting instances
of a very high order life form
thinking about well what would it be
like
if i was maybe without me hood if i was
a zombie what would it be like if it
wasn't actually me talking
what would it be like if there was no
reality it was all just me all of these
alternative ways of being that speak to
selfhood or its negation or its nihilism
now become plausible hypotheses for
which you have to search for evidence
and of course if you are just doing this
in your head and ruminating and
introspecting there's going to be very
little evidence available to you to
disaffirm
your hypothesis perhaps i'm not me um if
you don't actually engage with somebody
else there is no evidence
at hand
for to refute that hypothesis
so on the one hand that is a remarkable
capacity the very fact you can have this
hypothesis in your head i am not me uh
or it is not me having these thoughts it
is not me having these quantitative
experiences
is quite remarkable it's a very very
high level
ability which which i would imagine
where you you and i are the only kinds
of um sentient artifacts in the universe
that can entertain that kind of
counterfactual hypothesis which is
necessary to explore different models
it's necessary indeed to actually just
behave and have plans you have to have
counterfactual hypothesis about the
future and different ways of being
because it comes with um
it comes with a price
if sometimes you
entertain a hypothesis for which there
is no evidence on hand that could
possibly refute it
and certainly if you adopt a particular
behavioral strategy or engagement with
the world that precludes
soliciting evidence against the
hypothesis that you are say you
so examples of that would be
things like obsessional compulsive
disorder or agrophobia or um your
rumination disorders um where you
physically um or possibly even
prosocially
prevent yourself from acquiring any
further information that would allow you
to change your mind
and of course once you realize that's a
possibility
you um
you can always or you can also get into
the negatively balanced emotional
aspects of entertaining these hypotheses
so if i've got schizophrenia
that now offers
a very plausible hypothesis for these
dissociative experiences
why am i having these dissociative
experiences well one very plausible
hypothesis i am having i have a
dissociative order or i have a
disorganized thought disorder that
characterizes schizophrenia so this now
becomes a very plausible hypothesis
how would you go secure evidence against
that um well it becomes very difficult
because the whole prop point of having
these
very high order counter factual
hypotheses or models at hand to explain
your experienced world
um is that
they're very um that they're very
plausible explanations and it's very
difficult um uh if you have got
schizophrenia you're not going to be
able to trust any information anyway
because the great illusion
so it's one of these wonderful and
self-fulfilling hypotheses that are very
difficult to uh to dismantle um and you
see the same phenomenology um in in many
instances you mentioned behavior therapy
before
and um in a way that doesn't have this
quite the same horrible existential
angst that you clearly experienced you
can actually construe
many phobias for example
of the same kind in the sense that if
you are very frightened of spiders
you're very unlikely
to actually go and solicit the evidence
that would
that would confirm the alternate
hypothesis that spiders are not
frightening because you just don't go no
spiders so this is the kind of
hypothesis that maintains itself because
it's undermined the way that you acted
this solicitor evidence for your beliefs
but for you
of course you you know um you know it's
not a question of being frightened of
spiders it's a much more existentially
deep and worrisome notion that in fact
you're not you or you're not even a self
um and you're not even perceiving
reality and these kinds of hypotheses
that come along qualified by or
associated with
plausible explanations i'm going mad
are very difficult to refute in the
budget especially if you if you ruminate
on them um they will go away as soon as
you start re-engaging with with other
people
that's what i found to be the case carl
is that the more i talk about it the
more i'm speaking with you than just
speaking with people and not being so in
my head almost instantaneously it starts
to dissipate and also just so you know
there's a danger for the people who
watch this channel that it's seen as a
spiritual triumphant state to be egoless
to have ego death
so then just so you know when i was
feeling that i was then telling myself
but am i supposed to have ego death is
this what ego death is like and now i
feel bad am i just not strong enough as
a person which then i feel like i'm less
on the social hierarchy because i'm just
a coward who cannot deal with
who isn't psychologically strong enough
to deal with potential ego death if that
was even ego death
so that those are there's so many
dangers in this and i didn't realize
this i had this insight was in that
episode or experience that kurt kurkert
kurt something was like i was talking to
myself or something was talking to me
and telling me kurt you've been thinking
way too much this is you're extremely
analytical i never would have thought of
myself as someone who's too analytical
before it was clear to me that i was too
analytical and there's nothing wrong
with being analytical there's nothing
wrong with thinking but you've been
thinking a bit too much feel more just
ground yourself here engage in this
world more
and and there's also this feeling that i
don't love myself which is a strange
feeling carl that i don't have that i'm
a bit hard on myself
and i would have never said that before
i would have thought i'm not hard enough
i need to study harder i need to prepare
for these podcasts harder i need to
release more i need to learn more push
push push push
it was only then that i felt like kurt
that's been dangerous man like just
relax and and don't worry too much if
you
talking about this somewhat publicly is
a bit embarrassing because i do feel
like
by saying this like there's still that
part of me that feels like am i saying
this to give my way out because i'm
truly lazy and i want to say this so i
get the sympathy of for example you
maybe the audience to say kurt no no
you're doing great so then i can get i
can feel there's so much self analyzing
that's going on right here carl
anyway i felt like kurt you were
thinking too much just relax perhaps
don't engage as deeply as you have been
with these ideas don't entertain them as
much you maybe you're in a fragile state
right now you can do that later right
now take it back that's what came over
me and also this lesson that i don't
have enough self-love or self-acceptance
last night i looked up i was using a
rubber band for my thoughts like
self-administered aversive conditioning
when you snap yourself if you're
performing a bad habit so i thought
maybe i could do that with my thoughts
so anytime that i feel like that that
would encourage my mind to not feel like
that i looked it up and it said that
works for physical habits but not for
mental habits so stop that and what
works is act i believe acceptance
and
commitment therapy which is a cbt
technique so then last night i was
telling myself you know what try that
out accept these thoughts and i'm not
exactly sure what it means to accept
them i don't precisely think it means
entertain them but at least meet them
not with horror and dread and avoidance
but just say that's okay man you think
like that some people feel like that
sometimes so i started doing that and
last night was the first time in the
three weeks since i've had this that i
felt absolutely like my regular self
almost from five minutes of this
quote-unquote acceptance therapy and
then i woke up this morning felt like my
regular self like i'm behind my eyes i
have i'm in this world that was
fascinating
okay so i said quite a few statements
right there i'm sure there's plenty you
want to comment on what i'm also
interested in for you to put a pin in
your hat is what the heck does this
self-acceptance self-love if that's even
the same mean in terms of the free
energy principle okay so i basically
just poured myself out there
there you go sorry carl for you to pick
up all those pieces i know it's a huge
responsibility i trust you you're
someone who studies this you're
extremely extremely bright and you have
such a wealth of knowledge and i do feel
like what i'm going through is not
something terribly unique i do feel like
this is something that many people who
are on this journey of understanding the
world and consciousness in their place
go through this perhaps at some point
i think i was trying to emphasize that
by saying that you know it is a gift
that you're able to have these
existential crises um your there are
dangers that lurk which you've clearly
encountered but at the end of the day
the very fact that you can entertain
these counterfactuals is you know quite
remarkable you know
to my mind it's it would be the highest
expression of the human condition just
to consider we are those alternative
hypotheses where bits of our humanity
are just not there anymore or have a a
different disposition or relationship to
reality or indeed other people but lots
of things you said it made a lot of
sense
from simple things like you know
soliciting reassurance from others that
you don't have to do um any more work in
terms of preparing yourself for being a
good a good uh expounder of ideas or or
interviewer or book writer or or
whatever and you know that's exactly
what you should be doing that's that's
exactly
securing evidence for yourself models of
an affirmatory sort
and the more you do that then the more
the more that model will be fit for
purpose and you will have the right kind
of marginal maximizing your marginal
likelihood but
you're in a difficult position because
your job is actually to explore other
ways of making sense of things and other
ways of thinking things like you're
compelled to explore alternative
hypotheses
um and you know
you've described um
the you know the potential
um
nihilism and um
that i presume quite nightmarish
i can't now remember my nightmares but i
imagine that all of us do go through
this or we have nightmares as children i
think you stop having true nightmares in
your 30s and 40s but uh you know
that sort of you know before you've
really got that grip and maintain that
grip
on
selfhood and
you in your in your lived uh in your
lived world as part of that and engage
with that world before you've got there
you know it must be absolutely awful and
you know nihilistic to to occasionally
lose that and then you know worrying
that you're never going to get it back
it does remind me of certain um
some um drug-induced states you know i
can imagine that you're the kind of
person who will be very frightened of
having a very bad trip um and i think
very frightened of having one
yeah yeah so that that is correct and
luckily i wasn't well what i imagined
what i was going through would
feels like how someone would feel on a
on a terrible psychedelic trip
yes
um and it's interesting you bring up
psychedelics because of course you know
um
there is a move um
in a sort of pharmacologically assisted
talking therapists you know to to use
psychedelics simply um not to aspire to
i don't know what ego death means but i
i can have a guess at it from the point
of view of meditation and mindfulness
but there's a really interesting
connection between
the use of psychedelics
and the aspiration
of
many
meditation-like practices um that would
i think subsume the intent internal
attention states um of um of meditation
and you know current uh practices of
mindfulness which is really to try and
redirect your attention to the sensorium
and usually the intercepted parts of it
so it's like breathing for example
so this is the exact opposite of what
you've been doing it's exactly
deploying
that attention
all that um um
gate control we're talking about in
terms of selecting
what kind of information sensory
information sensory states to
engage and um determine your belief
updating
so putting it putting all that attention
out to the sensory side of your deep
hierarchical models your your constructs
uh what you're doing is the opposite you
you you've been actually wandering
around at the deeper the highest levels
of these hierarchical models that
sorry so in back when we were initially
talking and it said there's a black box
the input output and then there are two
black boxes it's as if you're saying pay
attention to the sensory forget about
the action we haven't talked much about
the action though obviously as in body
creatures sensory in action are tight
it's as if what i've been doing was
staying within the box and creating my
little sensations and actions within
there as little loops and you're saying
pay attention to the senses that come
from the outside is that what you're
saying or yes well i'm not saying you
should do you you you will do
everything uh
in the right way and under the free
energy principle what i'm saying is that
what i'm just saying is that the
skilled practitioners of mindfulness and
meditation
i would imagine of the kind that would
lead to ego death or
i'm not quite sure what that means um it
would
employ exactly the same kind of
internally mediated and sometimes if you
very skilled volitionally called forth
mechanisms um that are actually um
targeted by psychedelics
[Music]
require you
now to do all your belief updating and
evidence assimilation and sense making
at the much more the input level of of
the black box not at the if you like the
highest level which you could think of
as an output in terms of selecting the
plans and what am i going to do next and
what kind of person am i narratives that
we give ourselves that contextualize
the way that we behave and the other
things that we do um so you know i think
this mechanistically a really
interesting connection between the
notion of you ruminating going in
circles around your head exploring every
darker and darker
corners of your mind and different
hypotheses for which there's very little
evidence available simply because you're
not attending to the censorium you're
not talking to anybody
you're not for example you're not you're
not focusing on your breathing
and indeed you try and supplement that
with an elastic band just to get
yourself back to the sensoria ah that's
interesting
so and i i think that you know
you might you may
guess you probably are um skilled in
meditation um but that kind i think the
objective of
becoming a skilled practitioner of
mindfulness or meditation is simply to
get some volitional control over that
sort of attention
um that is paid to these deeper
machinations versus attention that is
paid to the censorium that underwrites
the psychedelic aspect the um
the allure of just sensory
patterns and
the sensations um and textures that you
get you know when taking psychedelics so
you know getting control of the balance
um um so it's not the fact you're
attending to your breathing which is
important is the fact that you could
volitionally redirect your attention
away from selfhood um
so but you seem to have got control um
by this acceptance and it strikes me
that you know in the absence of um
feelings of an emotional source that
were articulated in your description in
terms of you know i'm an awful person
i'm not fit for purpose i i have i'm not
well prepared um
i um i'm not able to man up and own this
ego uh ego death uh all of these
personal but quite emotional constructs
effective valence um aspects they are
also hypotheses they're also
explanations so the idea is that you
know anything that you can talk about
has to be part of an explanation for
particular ways of being that you know i
can be a worthless person or this is i
am a worthless person i'm not with this
person uh you know and you since uh i'm
in a state of anxiety i'm not in the
strength of anxiety we have to recognize
when we are anxious anxious is just a
state of being um which is necessarily
called for in certain situations that
rebalance this attention or precision
weighting and um in computational
psychiatry um
to make your belief updating fit for
purpose in this particular in this
particular context and what i'm trying
to get to
is why acceptance might have worked
because i imagine that if you were
suddenly found yourself ruminating and
locked into those ruminations
then very much akin to someone on a bad
trip who thinks ah i am going to be
locked in this forever this is going to
be my uncertain state of being for
eternity
because there is no reality that's how
it feels sorry how i felt yep
that
that feeling
will well if that is true i must be
feeling anxious you are then going to
look for evidence that you're feeling
anxious
and because you are anxious uh you will
experience certain cardio acceleration
certain uh interceptive um flight or fl
fright like responses
that will supply evidence that you are
anxious and then that becomes evidence
yes i am right i am now in a state of
nihilism
i do not exist and i should be anxious
about that and yes i am anxious so you
get into
a vicious circle so this is a sort of uh
good old-fashioned cognitive behavioral
explanation for things like panic
attacks that you know uh you quite
reasonably in an entirely base optimal
way
make sense of intraceptive bodily gut
feelings literally
you make sense of that
with the hypothesis ah i must be in an
anxious state of being
and that
conclusion that hypothesis gen then
generates autonomic actions that are
realized reflexively and the way we
talked about
when we're looking at the parkinson's
idea
and that will be reflected in terms of
cardiac acceleration uh neuroendocrine
releases
into your body and your body will change
and your body will supply signals
interceptive evidence yes i am anxious
so it's again a self-fulfilling prophecy
in exactly the same way the idea motor
theory means that raising my hand
is just
a realization of my beliefs but i can
literally raise my levels of anxiety in
exactly the same way but invisibly from
the outside but not when i can sense my
own body
so
if you got yourself caught up into this
joint hypothesis
i
am in a nihilistic existential state
and i should be really worried about
this and anxious about this
then it is quite understandable
that you are going to use
signals of anxiety and angst generated
by a body as evidence yes i am now um
divorced from reality i'm an person i am
you know
in a dark and nihilistic um
place and there could be no other place
there could be no reality
that's a hypothesis
if you can just wait
for the evidence
that that hypothesis is incorrect
simply by letting your body calm down so
there is no further evidence of any
anxiety
then you can find secure even from your
own body without talking to somebody you
can secure evidence ah the hypothesis
that i am in a state of internal
nihilism and anxiety
is a silly hypothesis because the
evidence refutes it i can now feel my
cur
not possibly personally but you you will
synthesize all your interceptive
feelings
in a way
that
provides evidence against the fact that
now i am a deeply nihilistic
anxious state i think that just is the
motivation for the acceptance it is
pushing through
to get to a state of mind and a state of
body
literally you know realizing you're good
and making sense of your gut feelings
so that you can now refute the joint
hypothesis that i am uh in a state of
nihilism and i should be jolly
frightened of others
because there's no evidence that you're
frightened anymore
so this was just a piece of um um
hypothesis building
of a you know a very sophisticated and
um
philosophical sort you know the highest
level of exploring alternative ways of
relating to the world you now have i
think a very useful insight um into what
into the gift of retaining selfhood that
we i think we all we all take it for
granted but it's quite a fragile thing
you know
luckily um you know
most of us get through the day if not
hopefully uh most of our lives you know
by retaining that grip and just you know
continue securing evidence that this is
the right hypothesis i'm a person i am
me i am functional this is you know this
is the way i meant to be and these are
the kinds of things i do and the kinds
of people i talk to but that is such a
fragile self-assembled and has to be
maintained hypothesis that you do
your that fragility i think only is
revealed occasionally and only to some
people when they have the alternative
hypothesis that you know i [ __ ] i am not
me or my or me is not quite as
functional as i thought i was or i'm
several me or b
how is it that you prevent yourself from
getting into existential crises when it
seems at least to me from the outside
that you study similar not theories per
se but the free energy principle is
about existence and it's about self-hood
so is your model so strong carl is your
model already so strong that you can
entertain these without worry that
you'll break yours or without that being
a potential possibility or is it because
you purposefully analyze it
dispassionately analytically
intellectually so that you're not
identifying with what you're writing
down on a piece of paper how is it that
you prevent yourself or is it
constitutional like by predilection by
personality you're not neurotic you're
not as neurotic as i am um
i think there's there's probably truth
to all that and um
and by being neurotic um you know that's
an entirely [ __ ] your neurosis are
absolutely essential to get through life
um you know i have a particular set of
neuroscience
um which you know i treasure and trying
to i'm trying to
admit it in the big five model
yes um
um
but i think you're also right that um
some people might call this mentalizing
i think what you were doing is that you
were
um
in a
raw enthusiastic and creative way we're
just exploring different hypotheses
about the way that you yourself should
it exist um um relates to um you know
the rest of your
mind and and the outside world
but for you we got conflated with um
emotional states like anxiety
and
your self-worth and those evaluative
states of being
so if you want to in your words be more
dispassionate about this kind of mental
exploration on the inside then you have
to um you you you have to train yourself
not to conflate the two
one way of doing that is just be cut to
mentalize
so mentalizing is usually taken as a way
of if you like
disentangling what we what we would
normally quite functionally put together
certain states of being
of a sort of
intellectual sort or you need a physical
sort
or just a contextual sort usually come
along with some uh emotional valence
effective um
uh aspect simply because that's the way
the world is so if you'll say um
very late at night
um you're normally going to feel
fatigued it's like you know
slightly less robust you know in a way
physically now it doesn't have to be
like that but that's the way that
normally the world works and that's the
way that you've learned to model
yourself
and
if you train to be a professional say
like an airline pilot trying to land a
plane at night or like a psychiatrist
who has to deal with these um has to see
people going through
these um um
emotional or valence or effective
episodes whether it's a sort of
effective in the sense of uh you know
mania or depression or whether it's um
the you know the co-morbidity associated
with psychotic states uh say
schizoaffective schizophrenia uh sorry
because effective disorders um what's
that
it's a mixture of um
um abnormal mood um with having
psychosis of the kind you'd associate
with schizophrenia um so it's having an
emotional aspect to
say delusions and hallucinations for
example oh i thought that those those
don't go hand in hand so some people
have delusions but they're okay with it
yes yes
some people have hallucinations and and
would not uh would not even seek medical
help or their family and friends would
not not seek
help
so there are people out there i guess my
point you know
here is that you can
mentalize it and build professional
defenses against the emotional aspects
and i think that's what i've done so i
think about these things as a doctor or
a mathematician not as a person
and if you want
if you want an honest answer the other
trick uh is to is is to uh not use
psychedelics but you should you should
try smoking so smoking is is smoking and
cups of tea
cigarettes or i actually smoke a pipe
but the cigarettes will do in an
emergency so there are certain neurotron
manipulations of neurotransmitters so
the first time a doctor has recommended
smokey
yes
well i hope we have a select audience
for this
well so yeah yeah continue could you
finish up your thought i'm sorry
you're saying the smoking of the pipe
does what because i'm not the type of i
don't smoke and nor do i want to smoke
but you're saying that the smoking does
what was the purpose of the smoking
it's just a way of using um nuancing
your neurotransmitters that control that
synaptic gain or the gain and the weight
you afford different
different parts of your um belief
updating so it has the opposite effect
of psychedelics basically so
that's why people like tea and you know
have a cup of tea come that you'll stay
calm
and carry on wherever it is nice cup of
tea cigarette and cup of coffee that
yeah that'll sort you out and it's
because all of these um drugs the
caffeine the nicotine they all act on
the same
kind of
receptors um
at different levels in your neuronal
hierarchy um that are responsible for
setting that gain control and gaiting
doing the intentional and the the
attenuation aspects we're talking about
so it's just a way of getting physical
control over your hierarchical belief
updating
a bit like you're about
i would have thought that the caffeine
would have the opposite effect of
increasing your anxiety
not not necessarily no um yeah
you know if well it clearly depends um
if you're very agitated um
then um
that could certainly be the case but if
you're if
if you are
worried that you might be anxious and in
fact you're not then desensitizing
certain um
certain interceptive sensations um
that register that in fact you're not
telling me your heart isn't pounding
that'll actually calm you down a little
bit uh if it goes too far then beta
blockers will be an another nice example
of that's what i used actually
all right oh well there you are so what
i'm trying to say is sometimes
with skillful use the use of a tobacco
pipe can have the same kind of effects
as a beta blocker
that's all i would say all right all
right professor
again thank you so much it's not safe to
stick with beta blockers and you won't
get mouth cancer or anything so sorry
i found the beta blockers work and
there's also some evidence of fear
extinction have you heard of that right
there's this uh professor named meryl
kenditt who i'm going to speak to at
some point she
takes people through phobias where she
gets them to be extremely frightened she
actually makes them almost manic or
panicking at least and then she gives
them a beta blocker and then there's
they still feel fear that day it's only
the next day when there's memory
reconsolidation and the emotional tags
are removed because of the beta blocker
so you have to have a good night's sleep
and then the fear seems to dissipate
drastically for incurable ptsd i was
trying to do that to myself so when i
was feeling some fear i would take a
beta blocker and then i would feel the
fear less still wouldn't be zero but
then thinking okay great maybe this will
be like my own intervention of a fear
extinction technique
yes i i i want that's a very clever idea
actually to combine uh beta blockers
with uh what
extinction or some people call flooding
so that yeah so that that's exactly the
kind of way i was um
counseling you you you would use the
people who smoke he was smoking to
moderate in the right
yeah
okay seriously
thank you so much i
will talk again and perhaps the next
time we speak there were some questions
that i didn't even get to from michael
levin from professor norman weinberger
who's a mathematician and and there's
quite a few okay
carl i kept you on for so long and this
is gone
well this didn't i didn't intend for it
to go in this direction but i'm
extremely glad it has and maybe my
episode could serve and your advice
that's a plus the advice can serve as a
cautionary tale and as well as some
practical advice as to what to do and
how to avoid situations like this when
exploring topics like this thank you so
much professor i appreciate pleasure
i look forward to the next time
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you